how are you doing in the corona
stay-at-home times I know that you're a
mom so that's probably gotta be elastic
good how you holding up and what are you
doing to kind of stay okay yeah I mean
right now it's just really strange
because we're kind of in the hot spot
and one of the hot spots of the United
States you know for the corona virus and
so and I'm also I'm in the Seattle area
three so we have quite a bit of cases
but there has I mean luckily we're all
doing pretty well the community um and
everyone's really taking the right
precautions but um Mia having severe
asthma I kind of fall under one of the
compromised cases and so it's just I'm
trying to stay home but of course I have
little ones who it gets a little
stir-crazy so we're trying to trying to
venture out in nature and not
necessarily try to go too much and
around the city so yeah well no that's
scary I mean Seattle um San Francisco
and honestly we all have to be vigilant
but I know you're somebody really loves
nature and you're so spiritual so I'm
sure you you want to get outside as much
as you can and what has it been like to
watch yourself on TV oh my god it's
really just like a surreal experience
because you I mean it's just like one of
those things that it's you don't really
it's a really good experience but it's
very strange watching yourself on TV
especially like but the beauty of it is
like being able to go back and watch
memories of what you went through and
what was happening and that's like I
think that's one of the most joys that I
get out of watching myself on TV it's
just being able to like actually see um
everything that kind of went on
throughout the journey so that's
actually really exciting I like watching
that now were you a fan of 90-day fiance
before the 90 days before you watch the
show or before you went on the show yeah
so I it's actually funny the reason why
I applied to be on the show I've watched
all the seasons of 90-day fiance and it
was just really funny that I was in this
long-distance relationship and who
and to live in another country so I'm
like sitting on the couch and I'm
watching 90-day fiance and I'm picturing
myself I'm like oh this is gonna be me
and Ashe one day and then I was like why
don't I just plan to be on the show and
I literally did it and it just it moved
quickly I didn't think that anything
would come out of it but it did Wow
so yes you and Asher on before the 90
day is this current season that's airing
on TLC we just love it I have to say you
guys are one of the sexier couples
that's ever been on the show you're both
so fit you're both so gorgeous so I do
thought concerning but people are like
wait especially with people who are this
attractive and awesome how are you not
just getting asked out all the time
locally why would you date somebody
across the world so what do you say to
those fans well so here's the thing I
actually post the video about this on my
social media not that long ago because
it was kind of a funny question that my
grandma had was just like why can't you
find someone in Washington and for me
and the answer was that you know I've
done a lot of stuff work on myself and I
know exactly what it is that I'm looking
for and what I want and you know I've
gone on dates that the issue isn't
finding dates or attracting men in my
life it's more just finding an actual
connection with somebody where we we
meet on a spiritual level that we have
the same mentality and that we share a
lot of the same the same likes and so
when ash came along we just really kind
of just clicked in all areas and so if
he just happened to live in Australia
and I just could not find somebody
around this area that you know kind of
matched all that criteria so so what
people are also wondering is you guys
have talked about on the show how you've
broken up a couple of times before
having in person so why continue with
somebody who's on the other side of the
world when your relationship is having a
good amount of ups and downs yeah I mean
I look at those ups and downs as kind of
growing experiences that we had because
for me in particular I had some
hardships that I went through in my past
relationships and there were a little
fish and chips and so just the long
distance and just a lot of like you know
we we have kind of a language barrier
but we also kind of had it you know you
don't really see the person all the time
and long distance is really tough and so
I think there were just some instances
where I was just kind of like I don't
know what I'm doing I don't know why I'm
doing this and you know I tried to get
out of the relationship but realizing
that this person you know I thought and
believed at the time was like you know
perfect for me and so it just kind of
brought me back to the relationship and
something that you know at the time I
really wanted to work through so you you
would say you were more just sort of
getting a little bit beaten down by the
circumstances and you had to push
through that yeah yeah absolutely
I love you saying that you like watching
the memories back but I gotta ask you
about a scene with ash he goes into the
flower shop okay and I guys like this
dude's irregular he's coming here for I
don't know how many women's so what are
you thinking when you're watching that
scene back okay I'm not gonna lie that
scene actually really got to me because
I was like I was like okay so the
perspective that I had on Ash was that
he was that he didn't really date much
and that he just you know focused his
time on himself and something like that
so when I heard that I was like okay
it's he like really just going through
all these women and buying flowers but
then you know and then I started really
like thinking about it and ash just I
mean it's part of their culture
to who buy flowers and do nice things
for any type of occasion or or situation
and so it really didn't like in my mind
and even at his family's house they
would always be putting flowers
everywhere and doing all that kind of
stuff so his go-to for any type of
special occasion or to like you know
lighten someone's day is to get flowers
for them so in my mind I'm thinking like
maybe there's just some some not
understanding with nice
said the flower shop guy said he's got a
lot of ladies I don't even know how many
I know but I try not to focus on that
too much it but like you know what if
that's what it takes to like if you are
dating a bunch of people but then you
find the person that you want to settle
down with you know through all of that
then that's fine too you're gonna change
well but let me ask you though because
we've seen from Ash he and he says it
he's a relationship coach so he has said
look I know what women want I know how
they need good feedback and he's kind of
talked about that and how ole women love
flowers no matter what so how do you
date somebody who's a relationship coach
and not feel fearful that they might
sort of just be manipulating or playing
you because they know how to do that do
those thoughts cross your franked yeah I
mean I definitely have had those
thoughts many times and that's a lot of
the reason why sometimes I would get
into a point where I'm like this
relationship just too perfect like
relationships are not this perfect and
there's something not right here and you
know that's where I would just get into
my head but then you know I really
started thinking my in my own mind that
I really want to have a relationship
like this where somebody has a growth
mindset and really wants to take
situations and try to spin it around to
like how are we gonna get through this
together and things like that and so I
just think that he has an advantage of
being able understand those things and
so you know that really actually helped
me and be able to see how to present
myself to problems in the situation or
in the relationship as well so I think
that he definitely can have an advantage
and it does play on my mind at times but
it's one of those things that you know I
don't know I don't know it's hard
situation well you you guys have as
every couple does on this franchise a
lot of obstacles were there moments
where you were questioning whether you
trusted him
yes absolutely and it just goes back to
like how I felt when it you know he is
so perfect he has all the right things
to say and you know if there's any weird
situation that I felt like you know
didn't rain right and there was missing
information he did always have the right
things to say and so that's where it was
kind of like it's this real or like can
i really trust this situation and so you
know it's just more like actions speak
louder than words and so a lot of his
actions would always play into his words
and so that's where I just you know was
able to come around and more be more
trusting in the relationship but
definitely there are trends you know
that had happened where it's just like
you know that's just the learning
experience that you have with someone it
sounds like you were a little careful
about falling into a relationship that
was too good to be true that that old
traits so I don't know how much you can
tell us we've still gotta watch this
season but yes what can we expect with
you and ash are you guys together well
okay so I can't give you any details on
if we're still together but we just have
landed in Australia and we're just now
starting this journey together and it's
quite a journey it is quite a journey so
I would expect a lot of you know
honestly I don't think you're going to
expect a lot of things that are gonna be
coming up but it's gonna be a pretty
it's a pretty awesome journey and it's
got a lot of ups and downs but and the
ending is pretty pretty intense but I
would just have to say that you'll have
to stay tuned and I can't tell you if
we're together or not but it is it's a
pretty awesome journey intense is a big
word is there any moment that you are
afraid to watch play out on TV something
you're nervous about coming to it
there's a few moments actually there's
definitely some moments where I'm like I
don't know if I really want to watch
that
yeah um anything you can tease for us
while we see you break down will we see
you to have big fights I I can't really
give you any spoilers but I will just
say that it's definitely we definitely
have some ups and downs what was it like
tell us and we're gonna see it all but
just tell me what it was like when you
first saw ash in person because again
you two are such physical people and I
feel like your attraction to each other
was so strong so what was that feeling
like you know to be honest with you like
I it was such a fearful moment that I
had prior to meeting him because this
was just so much energy that had been
building up for nine months and so just
coming around that corner to meet him I
just remember feeling like I was gonna
pass out because of just like how much
the intensity was like at the time and
then when I saw him I just like I
literally just like it was almost
instant like I just wanted to touch him
and grab him and everything just kind of
melted away so when I watched it on TV
it really just brought back all those
memories I literally was just like I
even started tearing up I was like oh my
gosh it just brings me back to like how
intense that connection was I don't know
so you guys going back to the obstacles
you're a couple on this franchise that
not doesn't just have the distance but
also you guys both have kids so what
kind of discussions did you have about
where you'd end up living given that you
had children here in the US and Ashe had
a son in another country across the
world how would you make all that work
well we had a long discussion about it
and that's actually something that we go
further into on the show so throughout
this journey you're gonna learn more
about how we have come together and
really discussed that situation when it
comes to our children because we
definitely believe that like we're both
two people that if we're very optimistic
about a situation if there's a lot of
love in this situation we're always
going to find a way to make it happen
and so just regardless of our
you know our relationship status that's
just how we feel towards anything that
we really want in our lives and so you
know having children and stuff like that
if you really want something to happen
you're going to be able to utilize
whatever it is around you to to really
make things work and so that's
definitely something that we touch base
on in this season I always have to ask
people from the ninety-day franchise I'm
such a big fan but the next three
questions one especially you since you
watch the show beforehand before you
started filming your own season what did
you tell yourself okay I'm like not
gonna do this on camera or I'm gonna be
careful about this what were you going
into it with well to be honest with you
I was like you know I I'm like such a
like and drama-free person and I really
don't like drama I was like I'm just
gonna have five but probably not gonna
get chosen because I'm like I just I try
to stay away from like the craziness but
it's just so funny because the
experience just like you know it it's I
call it like relationship boot camp it
literally like puts you through a really
tough situation in such a small period
of time that it's like you've really got
to get those emotions out and so it
really brings out you know like
scenarios of yourself that you never
thought that you would you know so it's
like it's yeah I mean there's organized
health from it all I honestly learned to
be a B it's oh my gosh this whole
experience has been such an eye-opener
for just like are you more dramatic than
you maybe thought you were it look
you're in an intense situation you're
meeting this person you haven't met
before you've been so you know falling
for it it's a it's a high emotional time
what was something surprising about Ashe
that you learned either like that first
day in person or in a couple of days
that would follow that was oh I wasn't
expecting this before I'd met him in
person
I think what's more just like really oh
gosh it's just so strange because like
we had communicated so much during that
time I felt like I knew him so much um
but I think it's just more of like the
physical things like you know what he
loves to put coconut oil on his skin
like it's an obsession for him so that's
why his skin is so soft that was the
scene when I'm like great transition
because I want to ask you and we're kind
of getting from everybody health and
wellness tips during the quarantine
times I absolutely loved how straight up
on camera you were about cooking with
cannabis you were like I put some on my
salad like the whole thing so what are
you doing to stay healthy and it can be
cannabis related for us though yeah no
no I have I definitely am hemmings super
into the health and wellness industry
I'm a certified holistic nutrition coach
and so um I mean my diet is very
particular on the anti-inflammatory diet
but obviously like I love cannabis I
love infusing my recipes with cannabis
I'm literally taking this quarantine
time to like really dive in and pair
strains with different flavors but I'm
also huge in CBD CBD is one of the
things that really really helps to to
keep yourself healthy anti-inflammatory
agents there's lots of garlic you guys
should all be having lots of garlic that
really helps too but yeah it's just
really just trying to maintain lots of
fruits and vegetables
can I ask you I just don't know when
you're cooking with cannabis or like the
leaves in a time like this how long does
that last like how long is it fresh and
can you talk to about the difference of
like the leaf and what what that does if
you do just throw it on a salad what is
what about health benefits of that yeah
so the difference so I think a lot of
people were confused by the fact that
like on the show you see a hemp leaf go
into the salad use it with cannabis but
there's different components to the
plant and so the THC comes from a
separate part of the plant and that is
the part of the plant that I actually
use I use like a Keith and I make it
into an oil so I do it through a slow
cooking process and I extract the THC
into them what and I is that for like
substitutions for different oils that
you would use at normal recipes like
olive oil or whatever that's the actual
cannabis infusion but the leaves the
hemp leaves have superfood qualities
they're extremely extremely good for you
and we actually have a farm here that
just got it legalized federally to give
to the public and people to be able to
purchase it and put into their food for
consumption and so that was actually the
leaves that were shown on camera was
from this farm and so that was just more
of like a nutritional benefit to go into
the silent but the dressing was actually
what was infused with cannabis you know
what well you mentioned CBD staying calm
right now I think we all need to yeah
cuz we can't and then you know you are
on the show right now are you binge
watching any other shows as we all try
to chill out during the quarantine times
you know honestly I'm I did watch
bachelor that's over now kind of a kind
of a bachelor fan which was really
really crazy season this this season was
crazy if you did where I am right now
where are you
I haven't I see a person's house he's my
boyfriend oh stop it you know you are
lying you're being serious
that is amazing I did not say bachelor
but it was a crazy season no it was
we're in the same realms we love the get
the wild relationship shows 90 days a
big obsession